hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep I'm your host and grace
Helbig I'm very excited because we have
comedian beautiful human miniatures
collector Lauren lapkus on today's
episode and this is such a fun episode
we talked all about how she got started
in comedy in Chicago to New York to LA
we talked about some embarrassing
auditioning stories we share a mutual
deep aggressive love of reality
television that we get into hers is
amazing at him so just in awe of her
appreciation for the thing that I also
love on such a deep trash level and her
new movie on Netflix the wrong Missy
with David Spade is out or coming out
very soon it's a hilarious movie she's
absolutely fantastic in it it's got love
it's got heartbreak it's got stunts it
also has some very steamy sex scenes
that involve elaborate choreography so
make sure you check that out and enjoy
this delightful episode of not too deep
with Lauren lapkus Lauren thank you for
being here in in these bizarre times how
are you holding up um I'm actually I'm
okay I'm okay I think I had like pure
anxiety for the first couple weeks and
you know I'm kind of leveling off and
yeah I guess that's better but probably
I'm just disassociating from reality
yeah yeah I can't tell if I'm I'm
handling things okay or if I'm just
becoming like blissfully ignorant and
complacent and I don't have
repercussions later totally totally okay
I you are so fascinating and you do so
many cool interesting fun things how I
asked a lot of people that are guests
that have like multifaceted things going
on what's your deal how do you describe
what you do to someone like a complete
alien yeah I think I usually keep it as
simple as possible and just salmon
or after but yeah I do so many different
things like you know keep my life
rolling along and and build or rear so
if I were to get more specific I would
say comedian slash improviser slash
actor slash podcaster slash that's
probably the slashes would stop slash so
many sessions so many slashes I get it
no take me through this start of this
because you're from Illinois originally
yeah I grew up in Evanston right outside
of Chicago yeah I got into comedy like
through improv and when I was in high
school I I was auditioning for like
every play at height in my high school
and just not getting into anything I
would get into like this go like sketch
show like variety show that the kids
would write and direct and stuff I got
into that every year and that was like
my thing but I tried out for everything
and my I had a teacher who recommended I
take improv classes at improv Olympic in
Chicago and so cool it was like so
life-changing because first of all I
really respected him so the second he
told me to do that I was like oh okay
I'll go do that right now and then like
you know push myself to go on Saturdays
with like adults and be in their classes
and like you know it was very it was it
was like I was very shy at that in that
kind of way but were you they were you
the youngest one in those classes yeah
so I was like 18 I was like a senior in
high school and everyone was like 24 ish
and that seemed so old to me it's just
so funny
practically 40 at that yeah yeah yeah I
was like shocked that they smoked weed I
was like what is four yeah I I got into
the same thing I think I was like 19 or
20 and I remember like people but I
looked like I was like 12 and younger
everyone like going to get a beer after
a class once and I was just like I'm 20
and I'm like too much of a dork to even
try to pretend to get into a bar that
was totally me - that's so funny where
were you doing that I was in New York I
went to I'm from New Jersey originally
so I went to college in New Jersey and
like started like doing stuff there and
then yes or taking classes in New York
and I was just such a same thing shy
like nervous
but like wanted to be in this world and
everyone was older than me so it's just
me like figuring out how to blend in and
fake like I was an adult no idea no and
I'm sure I was not getting away with it
either at all
especially because at one point I did go
to prom like on a Saturday and had to
miss a class and so everyone was so
supportive and like the next week I
brought in their like printed photos
from my prom that's so cute so did you
so you started in like Chicago and then
you went to New York for a quick second
yeah I was there so I went to college at
DePaul and in Chicago and then right
after I graduated I moved to New York
for like a year and three months it was
very brief I was in like a sketch comedy
duo at the time and we were going to
move to LA in the last second she was
like oh I want to move to New York her
family was over there so I just was like
oh me too like I just it was the best
way to make giant life decisions totally
totally it's like just so blind and
naive and just go for it
and it was the perfect time in life to
do it because I was willing to like you
know live like shittily yeah I mean
you're in New York for a year which do
you look back and think like how and why
did I do that cuz I do that sometimes
where I'm especially now I'm like I have
no I couldn't do it I have no idea how
oh my god I think it was perfect at the
time because I was just so unaware of
what I was getting myself into so I
don't I don't like look back and think I
shouldn't have done it or something I
think it was right but it was not easy
and I moved like three times within 15
months to different apartments links and
pulling my stuff up and downstairs like
with friends like just it was so not
stable
like the whole situation and I was
making like as little money as I could
to survive just so I would have my free
time to audition for things that no one
was having the audition for I was yeah I
have to be ready at all times the zero
opportunities that are coming across
right way right now so you're in New
York for a little bit and
you moved to Los Angeles yeah yeah so
then I moved to LA in 20 beginning of
2010 okay and so you've been in you've
been in an LA ever since yeah yeah okay
and you've been doing I mean I like
talking to you because I feel like I
have been participating in too many
podcasts as of late but your resume
blows mine out of the water oh my god
yeah how many are you doing at this
current moment well okay as of right now
I'm only hosting two which is really
good for me yes health care yeah care
but I've been guessing on like a
trillion because I'm available and
sitting at home so I just like posted on
Instagram yesterday because I wanted to
like post about the podcast I've been
doing as a guest and there were like six
and I was like this is embarrassing I
can't like I truly feel like I should be
arrested for being annoying like I just
like stop like but you know I don't know
it's fun it's always fun it feels nice
like see people and talk to people so
exactly I feel like this is the vehicle
that we're getting to socialize at this
point yeah yes okay so what's the first
podcast that you started yeah my first
podcast as a host was with special guest
Lauren lapkus and that's improv show so
the idea of the show is that the guest
is the host and I'm the guest so the
guests would come on and they decide
what the show is gonna be what its gonna
be about what their character is gonna
be and they make up a character for me
and I don't know any of it until we hit
record and so they just like only lose
their fake show and bring me on as a
fake guest and we have a conversation
for now those characters that's
wonderful
and that also I mean it gets puts all
the work on someone else which is good
it's kind of like it feels that way and
I think people can be intimidated when
they come on but then ultimately I feel
like I am doing 90% of it because I know
that I had to keep it going and like
keep it fun so it's like putting the
pressure on them at this at the top so
that I don't have to like do the work of
coming up with a character and then we
go from there
and then you do the heavy lifting moving
forward idea who's been some of your
standout guess
or episodes oh my god well I've had so
many amazing improvisers on that show I
it's so hard to pick one of my favorite
ones that comes to mind immediately is
with Sean Distan he's he's hilarious
he's so funny everyone should check him
out but he came on as ski lo the singer
like I wish I was a little bit taller
[Music]
and he made me he made my character be
Frank Dorito the world record holder for
most records in like the Guinness Book
of World Records
oh so I most wish is granted so it was
like this whole thing where I was like I
get all my wishes and he's someone who
has all these wishes so I was like
teaching him how to make a wish to be
taller oh that's so great but now you
ventured into a lot of podcasts that are
well I know the Star Wars one that
you're doing with Nicole Byer yeah and
this the premise is that you guys are
watching Star Wars for the first time
yes it's called newcomers we've never
seen Star Wars at all and so we watch
every single movie that exists and
spin-off thing or whatever and talk to
people who are passionate about it so we
usually we have on like a comedian who
cares about Star Wars to kind of balance
out our like feeling of like what is
happening and what is this movie and why
is it 2 and a half hours long where they
all two and a half hours long they it's
that's I I've technically I've seen all
of them but I couldn't tell you anything
about them and seeing you guys do this
podcast makes me think I should like
reinvestigate this entire very you know
powerful culturally important series you
have yeah what are the biggest things
that you guys have been learning through
this process oh my god okay what am I
really doing I I mean the scary thing
about it is that it's such a beloved
like thing that I'm afraid to even touch
anywhere near it because people I have
such reverence around it yes and this is
how I always felt I feel like I was
afraid to say I didn't care about it
like it's right like we can't even say
that like you just have to like not just
don't talk if you don't care about it
yeah but so
going into it I think we were a little
bit nervous that because the first
couple of episodes wheat before they
like dropped we were saying on every
episode like please be nice to us like
they don't know what this is and we're
trying to learn like don't be mean
because we were really afraid that
people were gonna just attack us right
being like you know ignorant about it or
whatever and so that was kind of scary
but everyone's been pretty cool I
haven't like searched to Reddit to see
how people feel about it's like that's
where like the mean people what would go
yes yeah yeah that's a dangerous
platform yes so I haven't looked there
but on Twitter everyone's been nice
about it and I think what I've learned
is like I feel like one thing that I've
noticed is that a lot of the fans of the
movies hate the movies and they're mad
about many things about the movies okay
so I feel like I'm a fan because I've
seen them all and I hate a lot of things
about them but I also like certain
things about them and I feel defensive
of some stuff now so it's kind of
interesting okay so you've added this
new like world for a lack of a better
word it's it's funny this see and hear
that people are so passionate in their
negative sense of like it could be
better it should be better yes and I
mean some of the things that people were
really mad about
I found that I wasn't mad about our
movies that they hated I'm like that's
my favorite one so it's kind of
interesting new thing yeah very cool
have you found a character that you
relate to or have become obsessed with
in any way I really got obsessed with
pork's
which are those little like creatures I
don't know how you described them but
one thing I love about them is that
apparently they were like I can't
remember if it was penguins or some kind
of bird that was around when they were
shooting and they couldn't get rid of
them so they just CGI'd these ports on
top they made up the character just to
like deal with this problem oh that's
amazing that's really wonderful
okay just Jar Jar Binks so we have
really controversial opinions that's a
very polarizing character yeah Wow
hot topics I also love that the other
side of the coin is that you're also
like obsessed with reality television
yes okay yes about you yeah you're in a
safe space here I'm obsessed I know that
you're doing a podcast about the new
spin-off of The Bachelor yes okay so my
patreon I am like I'm doing watch alongs
for listen to your heart so you can sync
up with the show and hear every reaction
that's a beautiful gift
people are kind of lonely right now it's
like something to do those your friends
over making fun of something and it's
been fun I also haven't watched that one
at all because the commercial that I saw
for I thought was a parody like I
thought that I was like this can't be
real
is it insane yes it's so insane well
here's what's so crazy so it's like
musicians who are trying to find love so
Friday put men and women in one house
and they have to like pair up with each
other and then they have to do
performances together which I haven't
done the first two episodes they don't
do that but they do go on on each date
they do they sing a song together
because it's their natural you know
thing that's their love language it is
cringy but it's also really cool because
I'm the bachelor like nobody has any
talents like they're like they're like
job is like social media user you know
those those job things but like I feel
like this is kind of exciting to see
people with talent on the show like
showing their talent cuz even if you
feel like they're annoying then they
start singing you're like oh my god
they're like amazing yeah and I can't
sing for [ __ ] so that's like a
superpower to me so it like it's a great
young people when did you get obsessed
with The Bachelor oh my god I think like
in high school I've been watching this
for so long which is disturbing no I
think I'm super Real Housewives like
deep deep cut okay what's your favorite
franchise or not what like location I'm
from Jersey so Jersey is near and dear
to my heart but then Melissa and I she's
also obsessed we were just talking about
where we're at with like the Atlanta
season was kind of a snoozer this season
and the new New York and the
Beverly Hills season are fascinating
because there's gonna be so much good
stuff oh yeah that they're just like
going in recording everything showing
everything and that's the part I love is
like when they start like breaking off
and talking to producers thinking that
they're not being filmed reported I love
that [ __ ] oh my god well the whole thing
with Denise Richards I'm like so excited
about that yeah I was reading that a
little bit I try not to even read like
the the tabloids walk before the show
comes out I don't know why it's like
spoilers I'm like I want to know what
happens in their life I exactly and I
only like last year started doing like
the deep dive Instagram look at them
follow some of them here and there
yeah and it's it's just fascinating and
I feel like they have to do that this
season with Denise because last season
everyone was like it felt very scripted
and it felt like they all kind of like
you know curated their own narratives
and now it's like oh I just love the
clip of her being like don't talk your
mic
don't talk your mics I love that and it
feels so real like us imagine like you
know she I love she's my favorite I
think she saw me yeah and she you know
she's had all this drama in her life
with like Charlie Sheen and everything
that she must be so familiar with that
thing of like do not say a word and
she's visiting her house her like
husband like don't say anything might
like you don't know what's gonna go down
it blows my vibe because she's been
through stuff I can't even begin to
start understanding but then she'll be
like oh I don't have a lawyer and
they're like it's fine I know Charlie I
know how to handle this and it's like
what do you mean do you yeah I've got to
know more okay is there have you talked
to any of the bachelor/bachelorette
contestants have you had them on any of
your shows yes I have I haven't had them
on my show but I've been on some of
their shows I was on Nick Vile's podcast
oh yeah it was very interesting because
he told me a lot of likes I asked a lot
of questions about like behind the
scenes stuff and one thing I've read is
that like you're not allowed to like
read anything besides the Bible and he
was like that's not true
I didn't know that but I wish that was
true
no I I read it on some like weird list
of lies about the bachelor guys but yeah
it was like they're only allowed to read
like you know religious texts and he was
like that's not true but like it's kind
of understood that if you're laying
there reading you know they're not gonna
be happy like you don't want right it's
not good TV and I'm like okay so that's
interesting and my friend Arden myrin
has a podcast about The Bachelor and so
I've been on hers and gotten to meet a
bunch of people through that which is so
fun like it's so funny meeting these
people because I feel like I am a
fangirl like I'm like oh yeah like some
famous actor in some ways it's so crazy
a hundred percent a hundred percent is
there have you thought about if you were
a contestant what your entrance would be
you know I have thought about this it's
such a it's such a tough one because I
feel like it's so embarrassing and
they're like so I my dream if I were
really trying to find love rise that I
would just walk in and be normal because
I'd be like the only one who just
introduces themselves and like walks in
right but if I had to like you know be
funny about it I feel like I would I
guess what I would do is okay so like
the lam limo pulls in with like a bunch
of beautiful people and then behind that
I'll be one of those like Little Tikes
like fisher-price
red cars with the yellow yeah just like
shoved in there in my gown and like
using my feet to like move forward and
fall out at his feet I think that would
be a good one I love it I think it'd be
fantastic what about you do you have an
idea I mean I've thought about it I
don't know I the same kind of thing that
I'd want to go and just be like hi I'm
grace I'll be at the bar I'll talk to
you whenever you know I'm allotted to
talk to you or just I the limo drives up
and I just be driving the limo and then
I get out of the no one's done right
even but then I think logistically I
don't know how that would be terrifying
to try and drive a limo in on a wet come
you couldn't do the turn in
I just destroy it immediately just
scraping along the gate I don't have
insurance
is there reality show that you would
ever really consider going on Oh God
I'm like a survivor yes Amazing Race
supermarket sweep well I'd love to do
that yes I think I would this isn't it
comes up a lot in my house because I'm
always kind of jokingly threatening to
my husband that if anyone ever asked me
to be on Dancing with the Stars I would
do it and it's like humiliating but I
think there's something so there's
something so vulnerable about Dancing
with the Stars and when I watch it I
always cry I feel like watching these
people like do this passionate
choreography and it's like weird and
they're wearing the worst outfits and so
I sort of think I would say yes to that
I think that would be fantastic my other
dream is to be a judge on the masked
singer okay I've only recently been
introduced to this show me too
okay it is it is fascinating and anytime
that I have turned it on I do get
completely caught up trying to guess who
this person is and so I won yeah I'm
always compiled ly off and I have no
concept of like who is in Hollywood that
would do this show
I'll see I've guessed a couple of them
right and so like a Jojo CY was on there
and I got it and I was okay I need to be
sitting there I could I can only watch
it in small doses because I get very
overwhelmed by like this is the state of
the world because I did see like Sarah
Palin was also on really no and that I
didn't watch that episode but I saw the
clips on there and I was a little too
like I don't know why it gave me a lot
of anxiety yeah and I saw that before I
started watching and I did freak me out
but then the quarantine happened and I
felt like I need a weekly show that I
get excited about and so totally this
became for me but it actually I think
it's dark even if you don't even know
who's in there it's just the most
weird show on TV watching people like
we're a frog costume and like sing their
heart out and they grind around on stage
I'm like yeah and the audience is going
wild it's it's so weird it is so it
feels like a parody of like a reality
singing competition yeah also I'm
stunned by the costuming I think the
costumes are so wonderful I'm like I
want to know how they make these
costumes give me their beauty yes of
that yeah did you know that well they
have to make them so that the head can
come off because like last night Bret
Bret Michaels was revealed to be the
banana I'm sure everyone knows it was
like watching him take off this huge
banana head was just the weirdest thing
I've ever seen
I just perfect yeah oh it's so wonderful
okay we're gonna take a quick break when
we get back I want to talk about the
wrong Missy new movie coming out very
exciting so we'll be right back with
more not too deep did you know that
there's a company that's mastered the
science of sparkle meet lightbox lab
grown diamonds they hacked a billion
year process to grow stunning lab-grown
diamond stones in about two weeks and
they're some of the highest quality
stones that exist they're always near
colorless always vs clarity always a
very good cut and always $800 per carat
they come in three colors to white blush
pink and soft blue after they're grown
in the lab they're transformed into
gorgeous lab-grown diamond jewelry it's
Beauty meets brain go to light box
jewelry dot-com slash Grace and use code
grace for $25 off that's light box
jewelry dot-com slash Grace use code
grace for $25 off sports research is
your one-stop shop for a lifetime of
performance health and wellness they're
the makers of the highest rated collagen
peptide product on Amazon and their
flagship product sweet sweat sweating
helps burn calories and sweet sweat
activated by your elevated heart rate
helps increase sweating during exercise
look at this science you can simply
apply the gel which comes in a variety
of pleasing sense too slow to respond
problem areas before your workout for
best results use sweet sweat in
combination with sports researches
best-selling waist trimmers like their
new neon waist trimmer collection and
did you know that collagen is vital to
help support the health of your skin
hair nails and connective tissues well
that's why you should try sports
researches third party certified and
non-gmo verified collagen peptides which
provide the best product at the best
price offered in a variety of flavors
sports research collagen peptides can be
added to coffee soup sauces or more at
home or on the go look at all of these
treasures for you and you have a special
offer coming your way if you go to
sports research comm and use the code
grace at checkout right now you'll get
20% off your order that's 20% off
site-wide
at sports research comm with code grace
at checkout ok I want to talk about the
wrong Missi it's wonderful it's coming
up may 13th is that cream yes ok and
it's you David Spade it's how will you
give the premise of the movie yeah so
the premise of the movie is that David
Spade basically goes on two dates one is
with Molly Sims who's like a perfect
supermodel literally and it's a great
doesn't age at all one knows she looks
incredible she's so beautiful and then
he goes on a blind date with me and I
play a woman named Missy she's Melissa
and I'm like totally crazy and the worst
person you could ever go on a date with
wreak havoc everywhere and he ends up
texting me on accident to go on his
corporate retreat instead of her he
wants to invite her and have it look
like he has the supermodel girlfriend
and he brings me instead and I just
caused lots of problems for him that's
very crazy it's like it's truly like
every scene has it something insane
happen in it yeah it's very fun it's
very fun your character it must have
been just so fun to play yeah it really
was it was so fun
because I got to be the person who does
the crazy stuff I feel like so often
like you know women are playing like the
like oh can you believe he's so well you
know so it was very yeah it to like be
the one like screaming and jumping off
of docks and just being nuts oh you have
so much physical comedy in this did you
do your own stunts cuz there's it's so
much like your energy you must have been
exhausted and exhilarated the whole time
that's yes I really wasn't I had two or
three stunt doubles who were amazing Wow
and they did a lot of the really hard
stuff and like especially like you know
were like I fell off the cliff and stuff
I did end up having to - I had to do a
lot of my own stuff which I just to make
it look right you know I had to do at
least 3/4 of it and that was hard for
most that's not like for like for the
falling off the cliff they had me like
strapped into this machine where I was
like spinning head over feet like just
get my face like you know doing flips
yeah yeah and I was gonna throw up and
that was my literal last day of shooting
like it was like after everything like
you're done and then they're like oh can
you come back and like the next day I'm
like spinning in this thing and I was
like we're gonna put you in just a solo
Gravitron for an hour and just see how
you do yeah it's it's really fun and
like you said you get to play this like
crazy outlandish character and David
Spade is basically like the straight guy
the whole time yeah there's also a very
hilarious sexy and I don't want to spoil
too much for people but I'm curious how
you prepared for such a romantic
endeavor well there was a stunt double
involved in one of those sex scenes so
okay so there were a couple stunt
doubles I think were used in some of
those sex scenes there's a lot of
preparation that went into them and you
know we had like just this guy I think
there's a scene with me and Sarah Chalke
and David Spade
where she had a stunt double as well but
it was truly like a lot of specific
choreography to get it just right
because a lot of stuff happens one after
another yeah so it was you know awkward
but fun and funny and weird that's fat
hat did you
use any inspiration from the contestants
on the bachelor or bachelorette for the
role of Missy because I can see a lot of
kind of parallels and similarities
happen and you're right there you know I
think those people just seep into my
brain yeah waiting for it to make sense
I mean that was so great about this
movie because like we got to improvise a
lot and so I and because this character
has like no filter I just got to say
anything and they kept a lot of it in
which was really surprising so that was
oh that's great yeah I was gonna ask if
there was a lot of improv on set because
it feels like it must have been very
cathartic just to be kind of the worst
yeah just screaming in someone's face or
like just being the meanest and grossest
person it's so fun you just never get to
do that in real life so yeah so great
did I mean are there any everyone always
asks are there any goofs and spoofs from
set because did you guys film in Hawaii
yeah we did which was so cool we got to
like a lot of the movie was filmed at
the Four Seasons in Hawaii so we got to
like stay there for a bit of it which I
cannot complain about that was very nice
amazing but yeah we there was always
something crazy happening because the
scenes were so over-the-top
like I mean there's a scene where I mean
a guy falls over a balcony and like
watching like this stunt guy I mean know
something that he left like most
impressed by was these people who do
these stunts because they're so
dedicated and they're like they just
throw themselves fully and yes things
and this guy was just falling like I
mean very far until like Oh Matt that's
like this thick like with his head like
it's just like I don't understand and
like there's another one where this guy
had to like fall over a a beach chair
onto like cement by the pool and he and
he like felt he's supposed to fall on
his head so he like falls like shoulder
to head and then like body down and like
it did hurt like I think like these
people who like actually risking their
lives for this art because I think on
some level you think like they're so
strong they don't get hurt or something
but no they're just willing
to hurt themselves in a way that you're
not so they can just throw themselves
into something so that was always crazy
watching people do stunts I was very
impressed kudos to them I mean yeah
stem people are amazing specimens I
can't even begin to fathom the things
that they do to their bodies like for
fun no I worked there's one guy on a
different thing where he was like known
for being the best at like being lit on
fire like known in the community as like
he can just like take it and he like is
awesome at it Wow he lit himself on fire
I was sitting next to my sees a lit on
fire and he's just like perfectly calm
it's just Jesus crazy that's oh god yeah
I mean how do you even find yourself at
that point in your life where like
that's your superlative it's like best
fire guy I know I would be so I'm so
curious what the path that they take to
get there but some of them some of the
women I worked with doing the stunts on
this maybe like they are clearly like to
have a gymnastic background or whatever
you do like so many cool things and I
mean that's part of it to make it look
really smooth totally totally have going
along with the premise of the movie have
you ever been on a bad blind-date um no
I don't think I've ever been on a blind
date but I pay I had I've had one date
that I think of as being I'm visceral
monogamous so there's not a lot of like
areas okay same saying though I had one
date with a guy who was like so sweet
and it was like a really nice date and
just it was just kind of cute this is
like when I was 20 but like on the way
home he like dropped me off in the car
and then like he went to like maybe kiss
me or hug me or something but his
seatbelt was on so he was like okay
safety first have you had a blind date
ever
I know I and I think it's because um
they terrify me it's yeah it's too much
of a gamble and I think I'm also like
Cyril monogamous in that like I can make
up my mind very quickly about whether
I'm like attracted to someone saying
and but I also am I think polite to a
fault that I could give someone the
wrong impression knowing like in my
heart that like this is not for me but I
don't want to make this person you guys
so I've like avoided those situations at
all costs but being the blind date sort
of realm did you get into love is blind
yes I watched all of what was blind and
that was wonderful yeah where does it
rank against Bachelor for you okay it
ranks I think I what I like about it is
that it was faster and more to the point
than Bachelor and I could binge it which
is great yeah what I do I would actually
put married at first sight above who's
blind do you ever watch that oh I'm
obsessed my boyfriend and I do our own
podcasts about married at first sight oh
wait we just started because it's like
the one reality show that he will watch
with me because there's like psychology
involved in it whatever that [ __ ] is
season has been at anchor I was telling
Melissa before we started that I was
like I haven't watched the reunion from
last night but I'm very obsessed with I
got to see what Zach has been up to oh
geez I watched up to that point last
night he's so annoying I this season was
so crazy I feel like they were just do
you think that they were the producers
were trying to make bad matches because
this is so weird like they've had better
seasons where everyone you know it's
much more real feeling yes and this
season I did go into a deep dive of like
looking up some conspiracies on the
Internet and the conspiracy is that a
couple Brides had dropped out like a
couple weeks before they started filming
and they were already in like production
so they just kind of plugged in like
Taylor for instance last minute which
would make sense if that's the truth
because she they say that she was
supposed to go on like love island or
something and her schedule didn't work
out and the video that they have of her
talking about like how she can't find a
guy as a very wee
dr. video but the yeah that's the
conspiracy that I read that her and I
don't know who the other bride is that
they plugged in but that would make the
most sense real yeah and I did see that
they have a trailer for another season
that's coming out soon because I feel it
I think they know they [ __ ] up this
season and so they're trying to sweep it
under the rug real quick and be like
well here's another shiny new season for
you me too because this season was a
upsetting with how bad some of these
matches were like Brianna Taylor like
and he just like wasn't fighting with
production the whole time it was so
annoying it was kind of fun to watch but
still like not what I came here for you
know right right right like I it's just
not the type of show so it's just kind
of that's kind of interesting but yeah I
do think married at first sight is
better than love is blind because they
it's just more exciting to watch someone
just have to get married than to get to
the person it's crazy it's crazy crazy
and and it's more like okay I like they
have to like go live together I like the
way it's broken down yeah yeah but yeah
oh wait did you watch too hot to handle
or whatever that was I know okay I was
gonna ask you this because I haven't
brought myself to watch it it's in like
the grand scheme of reality TV on paper
it seems like something that I should be
interested in but I don't know why it
just makes my heart hurt a little bit
and I haven't gotten to bring myself to
watch it yet I think you I think you're
right I did watch all of it okay I think
you're right to feel this way I didn't
really want to watch it at my husband
had it on and I was like surprised that
he was getting into it but I think we're
honestly so starved for like
companionship here that like he was like
getting so invested in their
relationships and he was like that was
so nice like I did that I was like
really but it's really just a cast of
like the horniest people in the country
yeah cannot not have sex and then they
tell them they can't have sex and if
they do that it'll be like they have
$100,000 pot that will be depleted from
every kiss touch sexual interaction
whatever and then they still do it they
they will they know the money is gonna
go away and they'll just be like I just
gotta kiss you it's been it's been ten
hours like it's like oh wait
they're just also morning so it's very
very exciting okay yeah I think I know I
know that I'll watch it at some point
but I just haven't gotten there there
yet but yeah that makes me a little bit
more excited to watch it yeah and they
don't know that when they're going in
there that they're gonna be told they
can't hook up so quiet they all come in
being like and that's cold like you
can't and then they all freak out and do
it anyway
Oh wonderful I mean I I also just wished
I could see the pitch meetings for these
show ideas that happen I would love to
be a fly on the wall just hearing how it
goes down that's the thing like I feel
like I have ideas that are that dumb all
the time but I just would never suggest
them to anyone why would I talk about it
like okay we get all the horniest people
on an island then tell them they can't
have sex and it's like right that's not
an ideal but then it is and it's like
and I watch the whole thing so exactly I
mean I feel like this could be a future
endeavor for you is like EP a-- a latina
do you have that dream i have that dream
i think it happened i thought i've had
that thought since i I don't know why
but like Teen Mom I watched since I was
I don't know 20 probably and I always
thought I like this is such a good idea
this show is so good like I can just
pitch something like this like this yeah
I don't know but do you have any ideas
swirling around currently right now I
don't really I feel like I'm I'm in a
state of like just ingesting things that
yeah do take it all in I'll see you have
a movie to promote so there'll be time
down the line I'll say you're on a
reality show later okay I asked a lot of
people that you know have auditioned and
you've done commercials jump DVD movies
all that do you have a stand out like
auditioning story or do anything does
anything come to mind because it's like
it's that I hate I hate auditioning so
much and I think it's like one of the
worst things that people have to do and
voluntarily do yes oh my god it's so
uncomfortable I'm like especially I mean
they're always bad auditions no matter
how good you get at this whole thing
like it's totally they'll mess up and
like want to kick yourself
I I definitely had out like auditions
for commercials that I found humiliating
because they can be really mean to you
at commercial auditions yeah it's a real
cattle call like it's so mean like
sometimes the people who are like
Manning the camera are like okay just do
it like they're just like okay they're
so dismissive like they'll bring in like
a group into the room to like explain
what you're gonna do because it's
usually like okay you'll walk into the
into the frame and then you'll like look
over there and they'll notice him and
then you'll be done like it's not like
too much but it's a very hard thing to
do well yeah like they'll just call in
like ten people and like they'll just
explain it now I and someone asked the
question I don't ask a question just
like I already I was gonna explain that
they just get so harsh I'm like yeah I
get that you hate what you're doing
right now but like it makes me feel bad
about myself so I had a lot of
experiences like that but I also had
this one that always comes to mind is
like I auditioned for oh it was what's
the name of that movie 21 Jump Street
okay and there was some line in it that
was like what are you a 40 year old
freshman cuz I think the characters like
go back to college or something in that
yeah and I was supposed to say what are
you a 40 old freshman and then in my car
I was practicing it and I kept saying 40
year old virgin and I was like oh don't
say that when you go in there like don't
say 40 year old virgin
I just kept me like just don't say 40
old virgin that's fine and then the
second I went in I was like what are you
a 40 old virgin and I went [ __ ] because
I knew I was gonna do it and then I did
it and I just screamed [ __ ] and then
everyone in there was like okay sorry
can I do it again and then they're like
yeah and then I didn't get it and it was
like I think they think I have
Tourette's I don't know yeah I don't
know what's wrong with me but I'll never
forget that Oh beautiful okay we're
gonna take one last break when we get
back we have a lot of Twitter questions
for you that are very delightful so will
be great we're not too deep
[Music]
too deep
are you stuck at home and feeling
isolated or overwhelmed and worried
about the state of things you don't have
to worry all of us are going through it
and there is something that might be
able to help you out better help is what
I'm talking about offers online
professional counselors who can help you
can talk to a licensed online therapist
and find relief they have therapists
that specialize in issues such as
depression and stress anxiety
relationships insomnia family conflicts
and more I've had a lot of friends use
this app and they absolutely love it
the convenience and the actual depth of
help that they're getting is Barna and
you can connect with your counselor in a
safe and private online environment
anything you share is confidential you
simply fill out a questionnaire to help
assess your needs and get matched with
the counselor that you'll love in less
than 24 hours easily schedule secure
video or phone sessions with your
therapists plus exchange unlimited
messages that's the one thing I've heard
from friends that have used this app
that the ability to text and talk with
your therapists at your convenience is
so absolutely wonderful and if for some
reason you're unhappy with the counselor
that you're matched with you can request
a new one at any time for no additional
charge
you can get professional help when you
want it wherever you are better help is
truly an affordable option and you guys
will get ten two percent off your first
month with the discount code grace so
why not get started today go to better
help dot-com slash Grace
that's better helped outcome slash grace
talk to a therapist online and get some
help
okay we're gonna get into these Twitter
questions but before we do I'm going to
ask you the two questions I asked every
single guest that's on the podcast and
the first is who alive or dead would you
most want to throw cold spaghetti at
okay Wow
I it's I guess I would actually my first
impulse is someone I don't like but then
I think I would be more fun to do it at
someone I like so I'm gonna pick Robin
Williams ah that's a great answer and
see that interestingly yeah oh I think
it would become an entire like half hour
long bit great okay the other question I
ask every guest is to tell us your worst
pants [ __ ] story or close call but
but you can only use three words or
three small phrases so for example mine
is college jogging front lawn oh I can
see em okay mine is hiking log toilet
seat oh shred of paper towel oh no and
you know in these times
anything can be toilet paper so fitting
well no follow-up questions to that then
yeah it was bad
Oh God I don't know that they're ever
good but it is a great it's a great
thing that brings us all together that
we are I'm glad that you had one on deck
immediate know it immediately oh yeah
okay here's some Twitter questions for
you Shannon wants to know what was it
like working on the Big Bang Theory oh
it was so cool that was it something I
never expected to happen because I feel
like that show was on I joined as a
guest in like a lot season 11 and so I
had been on for so many years and I've
never got an audition or anything so I
feel like I just thought I would never
be on that show so it was so cool and to
go into something where like they've
been doing it for so long it's such a
well-oiled machine it's it's and the
fans of the show who come in the
audience like watch are so excited oh
that's so sweet for the most part yeah
it was like such a cool thing to be part
of a show it felt like friends like
where it's like oh you're at this thing
that's so iconic and people love it so
much and I really loved it everyone was
so cool and coming into season 12 like
when they announced I was like there the
day that they like figured out they
weren't gonna do any more and because
was having to you know call it and I I
like had we just like a fun table read
and I like went home and I saw on
deadline like oh it's the last
they have that conversation and then
it's done but it was so cool and I got
to like I actually got to work with Mark
Hamill which I had not seen Star Wars
yet so I didn't contain it but I wish
now that I had seen it so many different
conversations could have been had
someone to know what is your dream role
um well something like the wrong Missy
rola was so fun and so exactly what I've
always wanted to do that I think my
dream would be to get to do a lot more
big comedies like that um like Melissa
McCarthy style where she just gets you
know she gets to do all the fun stuff
and like you know shouldn't sinks and
things and I want to do that that's the
dream thanks it can happen
yeah Shaun wants to know what countries
money is the most fun oh that's an
interesting question yeah I mean I
haven't been to every country but I've
been to a few and I would say I actually
I think Canada's money is really fun
it's Gayler full and they also have two
knees which I think are cool and I feel
like it could really benefit from
changing our coins here so I'm gonna say
Canada I agree it sounds like cartoon
money it's very cute yeah if Vaughn
wants to know what's your favorite part
of being on tour for comedy bang bang oh
I loved I really loved just going to new
cities over and over again like there
was a period where we toured for like a
month straight where we were going to a
new city almost every day yeah
that was so fun I love like I love
flying on planes I love going to new
cities I love just like settling in at a
hotel so being with the guys and like we
got along really well on tour and having
a good time I think the whole thing was
just a great time but getting to like
travel so much and see all these
different places that I might not go to
was my favorite part
totally is their plans in the future for
for more yeah we had some on the books
for the summer so unfortunately that's
all being pushed and I don't know when
we'll get to go to like live shows again
but hopefully I mean we already have
stuff we want to do so when it's back
we'll be back
nice girl named Katie says read the
amazing characters sketch where she
strips to brick by Ben Folds what were
which is amazing
what were the alternative sad songs that
she wanted to strip to yeah the first
shakes I used to do that bit at UCB like
live before I did it in my character
special on Netflix so I would I would
strip to fast car by Tracy Chapman and I
edited it down so it just kept going
right back to the chorus again and I
like humping an audience member with
like eyes and it was very fun I did it
in my special and she said no oh because
you had to ask for permission yeah Oh
amazing I didn't ask her directly but
somebody did and she said no and then I
thought of brick as being like the
saddest song I've ever heard so we've we
asked Ben Fulton he said yes and he's
since like reached out and like was
totally happy about it and thought it
was funny and he was so cool so that was
like such a perfect way that it worked
out oh that's wonderful and just
continues to add on to how great Ben
Folds is yes he's so cool
came up to know favorite Spice Girl oh
wow mmm you know baby
Oh where's baby I the great question I
feel like she's hosting some reality
show somewhere exactly I feel like she's
that I she's my favorite in my head
right now because I don't know anything
about where she is like yeah I guess
Victoria is like thriving and Scary
Spice is thriving and I saw a ginger had
a whole news story I feel like oh yeah
she like hooked up with scary spice or
something was that one oh really
I could hear yeah I could see that but
yeah also I don't know where sporty is
she's been okay I never remember her see
that's she is the answer then because I
didn't think of her yes 40 spice Maddie
wants to know Lauren what's one topic
that you would never consider having a
podcast about if there is one I think I
would say like love and relationships Oh
like earnestly yeah I'm like interested
in listening to other people talk about
that stuff I just I feel like I shares
so much of my life unlike all these
podcasts and I'm so happy to talk about
most things but then whenever I share
about my like like really personal stuff
about my relationships I usually then
like kind of wish I didn't say it so I
think I wouldn't want to have a podcast
all about my relationships but that
makes sense because for you that does so
much as yourself that like you need to
have some sense of privacy or something
getting a little bit just for you yeah
I'm gonna draw the line somewhere but
it's such a blurry weird line but like
it's almost meaningless but yeah yeah
Danny wants to know do you have a weird
or unusual hobby yeah I actually it's
behind me I collect miniatures oh I have
a little collection on my little back
thing there it's very far away and I
don't want to mess up my whole camera
situation to show you but good I collect
miniatures and I collect these little
dolls called Sonny angel dolls and what
are they should look them up there
little I'll grab one hold on okay oh Sh
take your time show-and-tell I'm very
excited
they're called Sonny angels okay and
this is one little dolls in there naked
and different heads so every single one
has a different head and you get a blind
box and you don't know what it's gonna
be so when I was traveling in Japan with
my husband we went to some little
stationery store and we saw these blind
boxes with this little picture on it of
this guy and so he bought two of them
and then we opened them and got so
obsessed immediately and we but we
didn't know where that store was we can
never find it again so I'm like we
started seeing that like you once you
look for them you will see them like
there are these weird things that you
think are nowhere and then you'll go to
like weird boutiques and they'll just
have them did they originate in Japan I
actually don't know that there I don't
know their backstory but like okay they
so I thought they did I thought they
were like some weird Japanese toy but
they I've since seen them at like
boutiques in New York or just random
little gift stores
so we made a rule that we can only buy
them if you happen to stumble upon them
okay can to them online
you can't seek them out directly no and
you can't just keep going at the store
and buying ten you can only buy two at a
time so let's get one yeah then we got a
new rule because I realized I like
befriended them on Instagram and then
they send me some stuff sometimes so I'm
really happy but we made a new rule that
was like okay you can order them online
if it's a holiday we know I got them for
Valentine's Day and I got them for his
birthday and we kind of like we have
like rules like that but yeah that's how
many are there to collect there are
hundreds and I have probably like 50 or
something but amazing there's so many
and I and there's and I keep finding new
designs and they keep making new ones
they have a cacti series now that I
really want but I'm like it's not a
holiday just go on those websites that
it's like everyday holidays okay do you
know want to know what was the best part
about making the between the two between
two ferns movie working with Zach
Galifianakis he's like the funniest I
mean I feel so lucky cuz I've gotten to
work with some of my favorite comedians
like David Spade is one of them and Zach
is one of them will ferrell like people
who are so funny and they're just always
always being funny even they don't mean
to be like I mean zach is somebody who
like he is the most amazing physical
comedian and so doing that movie like he
would just throw in physical bits that
weren't even a part of anything like
there's a part where like oh the studio
floods and we're all washing down the
hallway and then he just like stood up
with the ferns and kept falling down and
like sees himself with them and I was
like crying like I'm trying I literally
was pinching my legs so I wouldn't laugh
on the whole thing I'm just looking at
like this is so cool that I get to watch
you do this oh yeah oh that's so
wonderful and the movie was so good
and oh thanks that was fun it's there's
so much physical comedy now that you're
saying I'm like oh yeah that was so
intense and he does it so casually like
it's just like he's like flopping him
falling on the ground and it's just so
funny okay the last question for you
before we give you a gift for making
time for us is well someone's know what
is the best set you've ever worked on
and why mmm oh wow I'm sure that's hard
it is hard but I think between two ferns
might be my favorite one because I was
like friends with everyone and so it was
just like a really fun time when we were
improvising the movie 90% of it so like
we just don't like make it all up and
have fun and it was just a good time
like I just enjoyed everyone and was
happy to go to work every day and like
that's so sad it was over so that was my
favorite yeah oh that's so great because
the movie is so fun that you love
hearing that the process of making it
was equally as cool yeah yeah that's
awesome Lauren thank you for making time
and talking to us before we completely
wrap up we when we do these in person we
usually give our guests a personalized
fortune cookie from us to you and today
we're gonna give you a virtual fortune
cookie that I believe melissa has sent
to you and that you're welcome to to
read the fortune of sugar water up your
butt is not suggested but it's also not
illegal there you go
wow these fun I now have a plan for the
day Lauren where can people find you on
social media what you're doing and the
movie and everything that's coming up
for you you can find me on Twitter and
Instagram at Lauren lapkus and I have a
patreon at patreon.com slash Lauren
lapkus where I'm doing lots of watch
longs with Star Wars films and you know
reality TV and I'm doing improv on there
and stuff as well and recurring on good
girls right now on NBC's you can catch
that and then the wrong Missy on Netflix
May 13th awesome congratulations it's
okay guys go check out all of it there's
literally something for everyone that
you're doing and we'll see you guys next
time on another episode of not too deep
goodbye 2deep 2deep 2deep
not too deep was Christ headed back not
too deep as a production of grace Helbig
incorporated producer Melissa D months
edited by Shireen Lonnie Eunice post
production sound by Chris Henry and an
extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]